[Music]
wrong channel some happy Kwanza commits
and seasons salutations people who
somehow have the free time to watch a
video on Christmas Eve I finally decided
to do something for presents day that
wasn't an extraordinarily belated
Halloween special it's a wonderful time
of year where you can take some time off
of work or school I'm just kidding I
know all of you are only in school and
kick back with those you cherish to
watch Jim Carrey in a green fur suit
committing domestic terrorism on a town
full of people who preferred the
Cumberbatch version most folks associate
this season with skyrocketing depression
and awkward dinner conversations with
your racist uncle but I always think of
Christmas specials and the joy they
brought to me as a kid sure there's your
classics like Mickey's Christmas Carol
which is about the dangers of greed and
cruelty to the working class Charlie
Brown and his friends doing that dance
that shook all the furniture downstairs
at the point of falling over when you
mimicked it on the second floor rule off
the exploitable freak home alone six and
the 53 times the Simpsons celebrated
Christmas despite never aging but I want
to talk about some of the lesser-known
ones that always got me excited as a kid
in a season about selflessness in the
pursuit of peace superheroes feel right
at home these are my favorite superhero
holiday specials let's take a way back
to the early 90s when the world was
equally as scary and politically
volatile but the video game graphics
were worse than the t-shirts were all
tucked in bruce timm and paul Dinis
batman series is really good and if
you're subscribed to this channel
chances are you're the demographic who
doesn't need to be told that information
as with a lot of older shows with hectic
production schedules the episodes aired
drastically out of order seeing as how
season 1 consists of 65 episodes that's
the amount of episodes a show needs to
run in syndication which means they'll
play it on more than one channel once I
feel like I need to explain this as a
refresher because it's been so long
since any of us have ever watched cable
god I feel old I'll assume the DVD
episode order is the intended one though
even that chronology has its holes
making this the second episode of the
whole series Christmas with society in
typical fashion mr. J breaks out of
prison in the most extra way possible
before taking the city of Gotham hostage
with a twist - holiday special that he
broadcasts on the hijacked airwaves
Batman and Robin who is just randomly
introduced in this episode with no real
origin team up to go do what they do
best reenact the climax of their
favorite Stephen King story on Joker's
face what I like about this episode is
the way it lets Mark Hamill really take
center stage if this is really meant to
be the first appearance of the best
Joker then by sixties Robin Pond it's a
damn good one he gets so much screen
time to make jokes and act more animated
than ever I get it and I like how some
of his comments are even pretty dark
[Music]
what is the Joker's glove have a tongue
why don't they just spit out the candy
canes why'd the snipers leave their
advantageous firing position to chase
Batman on the ground why the teddy bear
crushed them if it's only made of
stuffing how did the Joker acquire the
mechanical engineering and robotics
knowledge to make this giant toy soldier
function as AI sorry I just I do that
sometimes I I have a condition so anyway
this episode doesn't really have a big
meaningful message about the holiday
spirit or why materialism is bad except
when the items you're hoarding or giant
pennies it's more or less just a big
wacky adventure where be man and r-tard
his words not mine
all o some clues do some detective work
and battle Joker at his camp iasts
culminating in a pretty perfect gag some
part of me wants to believe this whole
thing was just an elaborate setup for
that pie in the face and it was his main
goal all along it's a fun Christmas
themed outing that will get you in the
spirit of the season without lingering
too much on the abstracts which is kind
of ironic considering how most people
know this show for having deeper themes
and more character-driven plots let's
stay in the 90s for a little bit and
take a look over at the other runaway
hit cartoon from the time with an
insanely catchy theme song come on you
know the one you're thinking of it right
now it's about a team of abnormal heroes
and they're all subject to emotional
trauma and racially based societal
oppression the Mighty Ducks
[Music]
no I'm just kidding it's x-men have
yourself a Morlock little x-mass oh all
right okay yeah all right I get you you
were no one I'd be upset if they spelled
it right this episode starts out with
our old pals the sex men in their
playboy mansion with telepathic Hefner
as they all partake in some holiday
cheer beast makes a mess of his lab
Jubilee gets to put the star on the tree
Jean Grae gets unreasonably mad when
someone tries to help her cook look she
faints or gets knocked down in just
about every fight in the show while the
tough girls do all the work she needs
something to be a win oh my god
but someone other than third-degree burn
gambit isn't quite feeling the Christmas
spirit grumpy old Wolverine is getting
tired of all the cheer and joy and would
rather go out for the night
so joobs and Toad lightning take him out
to the city where they have a chance
encounter with the Morlocks a group of
mutants who are a little on the deformed
side and live in the sewers who are
looking for medicine for one of their
own that fell ill hey look it's the kid
from x-men 3 remember him lots of
arguing later they decide that they'll
heal the sick little guy by giving him a
blood transfusion with Wolverine which
is a bit of a gamble since we don't
exactly know the guy's history of
partners and it was the early 90s so
Wolverine seems a little sheepish about
it leeches life maybe there's a chance
is that what you want me to say it
worked twice once a long time ago
I don't know why the second time I
what's the difference I like to think
that's a subtle Deadpool reference the
show's already got a couple of those
anytime some shape-shifter or
illusionist wants to torment Wolverine
they turn into Deadpool for a second
which makes me think the show had some
kind of bigger plans to explore that
past they have together then again they
could just be fun nods like all those
Punisher Easter eggs - anywho this
episode astonishingly doesn't have a
fight scene the Morlocks just suck at
parking and Wolverine man handles this
guy little that's it the main conflict
of this episode is just trying to make
sure this sick little mutant kid pulls
through to see new years I think this
speaks a lot to the maturity of this
show since it's not often brought up 90s
x-men show didn't always need to be
about lasers and punching which is
pretty crazy for an action cartoon for
kids you'd think a big violent battle
scene would be mandatory for a show like
this but I guess the creator's didn't
feel it was necessary for this episode
it's not like the show wasn't popular at
the time because of decision like this I
really respect that it's a really sweet
and wholesome episode about putting
aside your differences for the greater
good and giving to those who aren't as
privileged and hugging small froggy
anime children it has something for
everyone
even the my hero academia fans a school
for teens who are born with superpowers
what is japan smoking that premise is
awful so more on x-men I don't like that
this guy is a table and he had to just
stay like that with a Wolverine on top
of him for like 40 minutes but overall
good show a really laid-back character
driven episode that'll put you in the
mood to go give of some of your own
blood to deform sewer mutants let's
visit the old DC Universe again and oh
okay Batman had two of these well you
could argue this counts as a different
show but whatever it's the same old [ __ ]
Joker's just missing his lips now
holiday nights is not as good of upon
his ex mass but a decent episode I'm
like Batman's last Yuletide outing this
one's a little less heavy on the action
and adventure and is more of an
anthology still has some decent fight
scenes sprinkled in though imagine
getting three short holiday specials for
the price of one so we got Harley an IV
using Bruce Wayne as a slave to go on a
shopping spree Batgirl
some undercover cops battling Clayface
as a kid I could have sworn this guy was
in Teen Titans but I guess they're
unrelated and Batman and Robin stopping
Joker's evil plan to whatever who cares
my favorite of the three is the Clayface
boss battle because he's just such a rad
villain and they can do such cool stuff
of the animation for him Vicki this is
the second time someone crashed
something heavy on an ice skating rink
there's gonna be some recurring imagery
in these so you maybe can construct a
drinking game or bingo card if you're
that bored watching my video if you're a
fan of Harley or Batgirl they've both
got some great moments in this episode
and this show was where they had their
best character designs I was taken back
by the fact that Joker has a gun here
and actually gets a shot off on Batman
how often does that happen in a
superhero cartoon like other than the
static shock after-school special about
gun safety if someone tries to show you
a gun don't stick around tell an adult
or someone you trust I can't believe
these are real things in a cartoon this
episode ends off on a nice scene between
Batman and his buddy Jim Gordon who
seems to have started working out
between art styles check it out for a
more even mix of action in holiday cheer
let's hop back to x-men I swear I didn't
plan for these to be an order of release
date x-men evolution is the reboot
animated series that somehow just as
cool as the 90s show despite being very
different with the main x-men cast being
changed in a hip and trendy early 2000s
high school kids with more modern
references like like the the craft you
know that famous film among the youngins
much like Batman this show created an
original character who was so good she
was brought into the can of the books
and even made it all the way to the big
screen stuff like this makes me wish
these shows were more brave with trying
out new stories because you never know
what idea might catch on in evolutions
own Christmasy episode Wolverine is less
of a Scrooge and stays home while rogue
and Cyclops go out investigating a
series of good deeds being perpetrated
by a man with angel like wings there's a
few interesting little themes in this
episode which subtly discuss religion
and its effects on society in the
individual without knowing for sure who
or what the supposed angel is people in
the town start assuming he has
the work of the divine boys like this
quickly take on a life of their own
growing more exaggerated with each
telling you'll find otherwise then when
they see something a little less than
holy they get a bit violent and scared
of him
rogue and scooter eye ball shooter also
have a bit of a discussion of their own
beliefs and how he's toyed with the idea
of a higher power himself a few times
being a show aimed at kids and assuredly
having some sensors involved they danced
around these topics and slightly more
vague wording and don't make any full
conclusions or messages but I find it
interesting that they bring it up
nonetheless that's sort of the extra
mile that made me want to include this
episode beyond the heavy philosophical
stuff it also has a pretty rad fight
scene between our three mutant heroes
and this shows take on magneto who has
probably my favorite costume design for
the character maybe I'm the only one but
I think this Ares look for his helmeted
face is super rad and I wouldn't mind
seeing it more stuff
speaking of Ares you also gotta love how
he's voiced by the new Kratos so he
looks and sounds cool this episode has
the expected Christmas cheer and
hopefulness to tie it all in a nice bow
before saying farewell to angel for a
while but he comes back later in the
show take a look at this one for some
nice character building moments some
solid action scenes and this adorable
goth lost multiple spider-man references
I guess remember that guy my viewcount
sure does alright just so I can get him
in the thumbnail spectacular spider-man
is the second story driven Spidey series
following the ongoing life of lovable
everyman Pietro Palmer and his ongoing
battle with love triangles and also mad
scientist's dressed like animals
sometimes this is a good-ass cartoon I
know people love to compare spider-man
stuff and argue about which is the best
thing and who is the best actor and all
this other senseless drivel but I love
this show just as much as the 1994
series despite not having much nostalgia
for either I didn't really get into this
show until a few years after it was over
because it never played on TV when I was
awake and it was harder to hunt down DVD
boxsets when you're like
twelve or whatever like evolution it's
pretty different from its predecessor
but the changes make it unique and I
don't mind a different take on certain
storylines in this episode sheer
strength
Spidey hangs out with his friends on
Christmas Eve but becomes the target of
the sinister six it's not the first time
he's fought them in this series but in
the time since last they introduced both
Kraven and Mysterio so the roster could
be a little bit more akin to the one
from the comics save for Rhino who
stands in for Doc Ock because of plot
reasons okay third time's something
heavy has been dropped on an ice rink
second time it's been this particular
ice rink and third time we've seen this
one I just love how much this show gets
Spidey he's clever and cunning funny and
sarcastic and also a little tired of
everyone's [ __ ] plus it's got the old
Parker luck I can't think of any
superhero who has to do something as
undignified as fight six super villains
at once while speaking like Daffy Duck
because he burnt his tongue on hot
coffee after getting yelled at by a girl
but of course despite being beset upon
by bad luck and acting like a bit of a
goof he's still a certified badass and
either smashes the bad guys with his
fists or outwits the ones who are too
big to smash it's a Christmas episode in
the same way die hard as a Christmas
movie it's more so just an unrelated
adventure taking place on the holiday
with the visual aesthetic of Christmas
joy in the background of all the
high-octane super violence I think this
is the same mall from the x-men episode
maybe all these shopping malls appearing
in Christmas specials could be turned
into some kind of conversation about the
commercialization and consumerism that
have taken over the meaning of the
holiday but I don't care there's
anything I don't like about this show is
making Kraven into a weird lion man I
feel like maybe they are trying to
combine him with that other character
from us since they're sort of similar
whatever this episode's badass once the
action gets going it's essentially just
one long fight scene with no breaks in
the middle and Spidey's powers and quips
are well utilized
of the too soon to gloat spider-man you
are the expert on premature glottal
ation I can't believe he just said that
check this one out along with every
other episode of the show because it's
great you've probably already seen it
eight times if you're one of my subs but
I'll recommend it to the three new
people who haven't seen yet or are too
stubborn to because they prefer the
other show Josh got a good
back-and-forth going here at DC and
Marvel let's keep it up
Justice League released the Snyder cut
of this episode with the 15 extra
minutes of Superman wearing a black
costume and something about time travel
comfort and joy is a swell little
anthology episode about a handful of
Justice League members celebrating the
holiday in different ways I guess they
figured Batman was hogging all the
Christmas cheer and excluded him from
this one along with Wonder Woman so just
ahead Canon your own story about them
doing something cheerful that involves
tree shopping or I don't know touching
their bathing suits this is the Tim
verse after all Superman shows Marty
manwich how to celebrate Christmas back
in simple boring Kansas
Hawkgirl in best Green Lantern go out
partying in their own ways and then we
see the flash trying to grant the oddly
difficult request of a group of orphans
to get a sold-out toy that's really
popular this Christmas coincidence I
think so this one's got it all stopping
a planet from colliding with a moon
snowball fights and bar fights
supervillain battles and seasonal
depression my favorite of the three
intercutting segments is the Flash's
story because I love his dynamic with
his villains sure he fights them and
puts them in jail but he's also kind of
friends with them he's so friendly and
kind that even the bad guys can't
necessarily hate him so they fight him
out of obligation to avoid jail but even
then he can pretty easily convince them
to come quietly soon as you finish your
drink turn yourself in got me again
flash
this particular villain helps him repair
the toy that was smashed in their fight
scene earlier after finding out who is
meant for I've only read a handful of
flash comics but this is the kind of
stuff I like about the character and I'd
hope to see more of this in his solo
movie when it comes out you know just
offset the assuredly grimdark
reverse-flash he's going to fight in it
too always got to fight a guy with the
same powers bless I like the little
message in this episode about how
there's no right way to celebrate the
holiday as long as you're having a good
time and sharing the day with someone
you care about and that you don't
necessarily have to be relatives family
isn't always flesh and blood sometimes
it's the people you choose for yourself
good stuff I know it may seem like an
odd connection to make but the holiday
season to me always felt like something
that brings out superhero shenanigans
because no matter what you believe in
where you're from or what your life has
been like or how hard you may have it
yourself the holidays are a time of year
where we can all come together and try
to help out those in need and appreciate
the ones who keep us strong that's the
whole point of superheroes in themselves
giving gifts to help the needy and
finding strength to push through hard
times for the sake of our loved ones I
think what heroes do is try to instill
that sense of friendship and kindness in
us year-round because maybe you don't
have to appreciate the important people
or help the less fortunate in only the
season of giving what our Heroes stand
for is keeping that same energy in every
season helping out and loving others
every other day of the year
when you're a superhero every day is
Christmas
[Music]
[Music]